the domain of the composite function is
the intersection of the domains of all
of the bits and pieces that you're
prettier the components okay in fact
that's so important I'm not gonna write
another time we need here two square
root function graphs okay now you
remember the square root of course is
just one half of a problem it's just one
half of a problem now remembering the
thread la a parabola has a stationary
point there is a stationary point so
right that means if I drew tangent at
the vertex the tangent would be
horizontal the green right so therefore
if I draw a tangent at the vertex of
this sideways parabola it should be it
should be vertical right so a lot just
looked around and seen the different
graphs of people are drawn and one of
the things they forget is there should
be if I draw a tangent to your wrath
where it gets a sex with the axis is or
to be vertical okay so let me do my best
to give this guy the square root of x
minus 1 what I do when I do this right
the squared X minus 1 is just like the
square root of x but it's the translated
shifted which way has it gone that way
it's gonna want you to the right ok so
it looks just like this normal square
advantage but I've gone one unit to the
right okay so this is something like
well there's my spirit of X minus 1 and
you can see it has a domain of X is
greater than or equal to 1 I can't exist
at x equals 1 that's fine because the
square root of 0 exists at 0 okay no
problem so if that's where I've got 1
then I've got the square root of 5 minus
X and so I've got 1
for this is success five okay now figure
out this two things have happened okay
in order to make sure you get this right
okay I don't you can just think oh I've
seen this before
okay but you because I didn't even -
just for a minute is it that one the
square root of 5 minus X careful so
weird things have happened to you right
this is actually the square root of now
what's really happening is this okay now
I know that seems a bit strange
okay like what why would I bother
writing you like this when that is just
that simpler is it not it is simpler but
it doesn't review what's going on as
well as this does okay because remember
you just told me the square next - well
when I see a negative one I go to the
mice that's correct
I see a positive five there positive
five so a lot of you would say well that
takes me to the left doesn't know like
I'm used to Nikki in that way it does
not take you it because it's not a plus
five it's really a minus five
do you see that like that's actually the
first thing that's happened I've moved
five units to the right I'm here that's
my starting point now and then that
minus sign place - the whole lot and
that flips me horizontally does that
make sense because the minus is applying
to the X which is a horizontal thing
you're right I can't have negatives
which is why what values can this take
on right which direction can this guard
the biggest value I could fit in here
the biggest x value is 5 right if you
put in 6 you've got negative 1 anybody
said if you've got negative 2 right and
that helps you understand why you've got
to go over here left ok so I'll get my
purse back
nobody's okay so yes okay so now let's
think about this right guarantee we're
gonna use another tool it's helpful to
us in order to work out in order to work
out those important points the addition
to ordinance you know just don't
randomly you look at particular points
first that you go from there if I'm 0
plus something at this point over here
at x equals 5 then 0 plus something is
just there's something whatever that
happens to be so if you get your ruler
up give a ruler up okay and you say I
can't look so my just reach okay they're
vertical to the intercepted
so without my realize anything quite
like that and you can see this another
way which does exactly the same thing
namely x equals 1 now there's one more
other point that's important to me okay
and that's the point where these two are
equal that's really easy to plot I'm
just going to be twice as high so that
looks to be something like looks like
it's gonna be somewhere up there now
from here
how am I thinking about this right well
you've got two things that are positive
right what's growing what's decreasing
okay now you've got to get up to there
all right so you know you're gonna be
going on right but you can also think of
this in a logical way like and this is
something you're gonna have to exercise
more as we go further to this topic
what's the increasing ones growing which
one is bigger which ones rate is more
significant okay now think about this
right remember I said look you're gonna
have a vertical tangent here right so
what does that mean about the gradient
at this point well if if I could give it
a number right I would say it's really
really high very safe if I just go one
like a tiny bit over the gradient that
point right there is insane like a
billion or something like that any
arbitrarily high number okay so in other
words this is growing super fast this is
decreasing is it decreasing fast or slow
slow really really slow right it's quite
shallow okay that's why this even though
this increasing decrease they don't just
cancel out right the increase is more
important than the decrease
I'm telling you what I'm for making a
wise choice
you really should be doing Jenna
okay now therefore all that to say right
sometimes but you can add and subtract
like things that are increasing or
decreasing they cancel each other out
we'll see examples of that plenty right
but here this guy is increasing faster
than this one is decreasing so when you
put them together when you add the
ordinates that's why you have it
increasing like so now in exactly the
same way I make the argument in Reverse
as I cross over this point and a cross
over now
this guy is going to start to decrease
faster then this is increasing do you
see that and that's why the graph that
I've got has inputs right so I should
indicate what those influence are and I
accept coordinates for these things
right this is gonna be one comma but
when I put x equals one is I'm gonna get
the square root of zero plus the square
root of x equals x equals four so this
is one competition and by analogy over
here I've gone also